hold on okay holy spirit activate oh no
holy spirit activate holy spirit
activate activate activate all right
let's go
yep that's kim kardashian and daughter
north just casually taking over tick
tock you know social media is such a
great tool and a great way to show off
the adorableness going on at home
[Music]
to kick off thanksgiving weekend the
reality star joined tick tock with an
account called kim minort
and so far the fans have been treated to
some amazing mother-daughter collabs
[Music]
whether by singing dancing or just
showing off some at home antics
[Applause]
[Music]
tick tock is on track to become the
business mogul's latest social media
triumph
[Music]
and following this tour of the
kardashians thanksgiving spread i
finally have a really good idea for
christmas kim and north showed off their
homes holiday makeover
it's beginning to look a lot like
christmas
[Music]
everywhere you go but of course courtney
and penelope are the og mother-daughter
tick-tockers in this family that could
be
really cute their account titled pee in
court hit the social media platform last
month
and look even quartz beyonce travis
barker gets in on the fun
[Music]
in between the holiday home decor the
two treat fans to beauty tutorials home
tours and moments designed to make
anyone crave
you call marshmallows again
[Music]